what's going on guys today the second
trailer for my
academia season 5 came out and in this
video we're going to be breaking it down
including the details that you might
have missed whilst this second trailer
does have a good amount of new footage
there are still a bunch of shots that
were also in the previous trailer
so i won't be talking about those
moments to avoid repeating myself
if you haven't seen it i did do a video
breaking down the first trailer so be
sure to check that out after this one if
you haven't seen it already
and yeah let's just get into it trailer
2 begins with this ominous scene of
class 1b
approaching class 1a in this shot the
members of class 1b can only be
identified by their silhouettes
but we definitely know it's them because
who else has a head like this
we then get a reaction shot of deku
tokyomi and koda
before the trailer switches over to the
main event and no i'm not talking about
the battles
the main event is shinzo's introduction
in this scene we see izawa and vlad king
introducing shinzo
to both the hero classes as he will also
be participating in the training
exercise
shinzo's desire to join the hero course
was made clear from the first moment we
met him
and just like the sports festival season
5 will provide him with another
opportunity
to show off his skills to the hero
course teachers anyway we briefly see
shinzo's persona chords in action
and these are a support item that he
acquired since the last time we saw him
later in the trailer we also see tokyomi
using a support item for the first time
and these are his thermal goggles which
is suited to a character like him who
thrives
in the darkness as the name suggests
thermal imagery lets him see in the dark
to an extent
so yeah it's pretty useful for tokyo
army the trailer moves on to this moment
of izawa
telling the students how they can
improve with denki being particularly
animated
this moment was after the conclusion of
the first battle
in which we'll get to see some awesome
quirk upgrades from certain characters
including suba rasa from class 1b who
created this air prism which we can now
see in full view
in the last trailer we did see this air
prism but it was only like a tiny little
bit
but here we can see the whole thing it
looks pretty good and definitely an
upgrade compared to what he used to be
able to do
following this we got a beautiful shot
of midoriya outside ua
and this will most likely be shown in
episode 1 of season 5
after this dream sequence which we saw
at the end of the last season
the rest of this trailer is a series of
cool action shots and also a bunch of
quirks that we've never seen used before
we get to see hiroshima's unbreakable
form not to mention todoroki going all
out in this beautiful sequence the
animation right here is giving me
serious season 2 vibes which was
arguably the pinnacle of animation for
the series so far
we also get to see bakago doing his
thing and yeah he will be relentless
during season five and
if you notice during this explosion it
literally spells out the word boom as he
does it
if they keep up with this kind of
attention to detail then yeah season
five is gonna be just
absolutely epic we get some more rapid
scenes towards the end
such as kaminari attempting to
electrocute beast ibarra using her vines
on a massive scale
and either going all out in this shot
right here if you're wondering what this
ball of energy is i realize that it's
coming out of edith's engines as he
activates his super move
it's purely just a visual thing that the
animators have added in
i guess just to make it look cooler but
yeah at the beginning when i saw this i
was like where is this ball of energy
coming from like i don't remember this
being in the manga we also got tetsu
tetsu punching through shoto's eyes
which looks pretty good when compared to
the same moment from the manga
and later in the trailer we see tetsu
tetsu watching again as shoto begins to
channel his inner endeavor
kendo vs momo was also briefly shown
with the latter attempting to create a
barrier to protect herself
from kendo's massive hand with that said
before we end the video
let's briefly talk about the new quirks
that we saw in this trailer
the first new power we get to see is a
transformation quirk called black
which is possessed by one of the class
1b students while we have seen him
before
we've never seen his ability in action
season 5 will be his first
relevant introduction to the majority of
the fan base
the next new quirk is from pony who is
as far as i know she's the only american
student that goes to ua
and her power is called horn cannon i
won't go into these specifics so that i
don't spoil it completely but as you can
see from the trailer you know she can
shoot horns from her head and then
control them with telekinesis
this scale quirk is another one that
we've not properly seen before
although in fairness we did see it
briefly used during the sports festival
but it was in a totally different way
in the trailer we can see the scales
being shot out so yeah that's going to
be pretty interesting in season 5.
beast is the only other new quirk in
this trailer that we haven't seen before
between
seasons one to four uh and yeah it's a
transformation quirk as you can tell you
know when you compare his beast form
to his regular form there is a big
difference there the season five trailer
ends with midoriya jumping in the air
and then another shot of him looking
super cheerful be sure to let me know in
the comments what you thought of this
trailer
and has it increased your hype for
season 5. thanks for watching as always
and be sure to drop a like if you like
this video
and until the next one peace out